das Land von Liebe und
Frivolität
tatsächlich sind viele
Franzosen Männer wie Frauen
stolz auf ihre
Verführungskünste
wenn es sich allerdings nicht um
einen Führer
sondern um einen Angriff handelt
wird von den Frauen erwartet
dass sich streiten
so erstattete die
Schriftstellerin Tristane Banon
als jetzt nach der Affäre in
den USA Anzeige gegen Dominique
strauss-kahn wegen versuchter
Vergewaltigung dabei geht der
Vorfall auf das Jahr 2003
zurück damals für die Tiere
Mutter von einer Anzeige ab
sie fürchtete ihre Tochter
könne in Verruf geraten Jackpot
werde demnächst ich habe einige
Wochen nach dem Vorfall mit
strauss-kahn gesprochen er sagte
er habe komplett den Kopf
verloren weil er einige Jahre
zuvor eine sexuelle Beziehung
mit mir hatte
und als er dann meine Tochter
gesehen habe habe ihn das
animiert wir haben nach der
Mutter auch die Tochter haben
wollen Malki in der Nähe
Norwegen
die beste vergab in der 4 ein
der Angriff
wäre völlig unter den Teppich
gekehrt worden wären nicht
ausländische Journalisten auf
die Fährte bekommen
was er denn der Bestseller des
ist ja so ein Riesending
geworden
am 15
im Mai hatte ich plötzlich die
Wahl entweder zu sagen «Jaja
meine Tochter lügt etwas nicht
stimmt oder ich musste die
Wahrheit sagen ja ja es gab
bereits einen Fall in Frankreich
da war es logisch dass meine
Tochter jetzt auch gegen
strauss-kahn Anzeige erstattet
Dollar in der Musik
Prozesse er definiert Bach
Bauchdecke an deshalb wird sich
Dominique strauss-kahn
nun womöglich in Paris vor
Gericht verantworten müssen
seine Festnahme im Mai
erschütterte Frankreich die
kaum eine andere Affären denn
er war laut Umfragen der
aussichtsreichste Kandidat für
die Präsidentenwahlen
viele Landsleute stellten sich
die Frage erst jetzt das dürfen
Männer und was nicht
hier bei der Anlaufstelle für
Vergewaltigungsopfer sehen sind
dass viele Französinnen durch
die strauss-kahn nach Werder
wachsamer geworden sind
in der Logik es kann kein
Befreiungsschlag er betraf vor
allem Frauen die sich Klein
gefühlt haben gegenüber einer
Person gemacht hat
die haben sich gesagt wenn ein
Zimmermädchen den Mut hat offen
auszusprechen was hier passiert
ist dann ich hab ich das Auto in
die Luft
Soziologen
gehen von über 75 tausend
Sexualdelikten pro Jahr in
Frankreich aus
aber wenn ich dann mal diesem
zehnten Angriff kommt es auch
zur Anklage eine regelrechte
Ausnahme der Fall Martin Zimon
monatelang musste sich die
Rathaus Angestellte dies
sexuellen übergriffe ihres
Bürgermeisters gefallen lassen
erste echte Unterstützung
anderer Frauen von Stephan Roth
dem Politiker vor Gericht zu
bringen
Völker ich hatte Angst vor ihm
nicht davor dass er körperlich
total blöd aber ich hatte Angst
vor seiner Position
als Senator und Bürgermeister
ich dachte wenn ich was sage
dann schmeißt er mich raus aber
ich brauchte diese Arbeit als
Hausmeisterin weil ich meine
Kinder alleine erziehen seine
Gegner vor wir bevorzugen
nachdem Timo gewandt deren
Prozesse der Senator wurde zu
einer Geldstrafe verurteilt
weder gegen betrug die Hauptlast
sie verlor ihre Arbeit und ihre
Dienstwohnung
ein Jackpot Burgunde verboten
waren
wenn man sich dafür einsetzt
dass sexuelle Belästigungen und
sexueller Gewalt am Arbeitsplatz
aufhören
in der Tat vorgeworfen ein
zerstörter dieses wundervolle
französische Modell der
Verführung
es heißt dann all diejenigen
zum Beispiel die Medien die
über die traurige Realität
sprechen machen unsere Kultur
kaputt als Rente hacker-pschorr
Einzelrennen
die neue feministische
Zeitschrift q selbst
denn das Klischee vom
französischen Verführer Typus
aufs Korn
nicht einfach in einem Land in
dem ist vielleicht mehr als
anderswo zum Privileg der
mächtigen gehört auch sexuell
über unter die Ebene zu
verfügen und womit Machtgehabe
von Männern Kokott jetzt wird
prekär vorne 6 wir waren extrem
schockiert darüber
«dass manche intellektuelle
strauss-kahn verteidigt haben
sie haben ihre feministischen
überzeugung vergessen einfach
keine ihr Freund ist und sie zu
werden Kasse genommen werden
mehr
diese Wellen die Affäre um
Dominique strauss-kahn dort
sollen bald vergessen sein
die Diskussion über die Grenzen
von Verführungskunst und
sexuellen übergriff
hat in Frankreich gerade erst
begonnen